so so if you were somebody who was in
charge and now that we have some more
data would you say open it back up to
getting the economy going and businesses
opening back up is it is that what
you're suggesting that it's time for us
to do that yeah I would institute
randomized testing of the entire
population randomized we don't have to
test every single statistics works we
can we can do random testing I would
institute masks and social distancing
and I would put people back to work and
for those that were most at risk I would
say continue to quarantine and and tell
this abates but here's the deal
those people are going to want to stay
cooped up for 12 to 18 months the doctor
foul she thinks it's going to take to
get a vaccine so what I what I predict
will happen is people will be wearing
these masks for about two weeks and then
they'll be back to work and then the
masks are going to come off and then
they're just going to start living their
lives again I think what we what we have
now is mass hysteria and mass fear and
we need to get back and in contact with
each other again and as we get back to
in contact with each other again we'll
realize that we're not gonna die every
time we see somebody and when that
happens we're gonna get tired of wearing
masks and and you know doing the elbow
bump and it's gonna go back to the way
things were but we need to be able to
get people out of their homes and in
contact with each other and actually
running the economy because if we don't
we're gonna be in big trouble in the
country is not gonna be able to deal
with a social disorder that's gonna come
from this long-term economic shutdown is
the way of doing business forever
changed or no we'll forget about this
and move on in the next six twelve
months we'll forget about it and move on
you think we're gonna forget about it
and move on I think we're gonna forget
about it and move on interesting people
have very short memories they just need
to get rid of the fear create some
certainty understand that no everybody's
not gonna die some people won't even get
sick most people 85
percent of the people or so will not
even have symptoms it's a big number 85
percent of 20 minutes and you're hearing
about some people even be an immune to
it meaning they can't even get it like
even if you and that that would be that
would be you know the eighty five
percent that don't have symptoms I mean
essentially disease really comes from
the reaction of the body to fighting the
organism in and in fact that you have
some pre-existing medical condition or
you're elderly so you're thinking a part
of the solution is immediate hurt
immunity with a form of quarantine for
those who are above a certain age to
keep staying safe until this goes back
to normal so you're for a form of heart
immunity so yes but I'm also for
flattening the curve I recognize that
and particularly and this is what I said
also in the beginning the entire country
is not New York if you've lived in New
York and I have you understand the
population density is such that it needs
to act differently than Fresno
California where I grew up
right we're not packed like sardines in
Fresno California but we definitely are
in Manhattan and forty percent of the
people are riding the the subway so
that's a different situation so each
each locality in the United States needs
to have different rules peculiar to that
locality and then we need to take four
top precautions as I said so I'm not
against flattening the curve and so if
we wanted to take two weeks off until we
can get the right procedures so that
people were understood that you wear a
mask not to protect yourself you wear a
mask to protect other people from what's
coming what you're breathing out so if
you are asymptomatic you're not
breathing those out up to thirteen feet
away from your body and so and then not
shaking hands again that makes sense in
this current environment but here's the
deal if we don't have a vaccine in
eighteen months like foul Chi says then
what are those people that are at risk
going to do I mean there's been
people that are 85 years old that have
lived through the virus people do not do
well if they're cooped up in their house
for months on end and this country won't
do well economically if we do that so
you had to do some curve flattening but
then we needed to get right back to work
and really understand that we're gonna
get through this it's not this
coronavirus is not so deadly so much
more deadly than the common flu we lost
60,000 people last year button to the
flu by the way